Now, we're starting with November the 10th, 1923, and this is the most wonderful teaching
on nothingness.
It's absolutely brilliant.
So I want to give you a question and answer before we even start.
And the question is, who is the greatest in the Kingdom of Heaven?
And that's in Luke 22 verses 24 to 27.
And the second one is, who is the least in the Kingdom of Heaven?
Did I say Luke 22?
Okay.
Who is the least in the Kingdom of Heaven is Matthew 20, 24 to 28.
So who is the greatest and who is the least?
Remember, there were some discussions between the apostles about this.
Right up to Luke says, right up into the Last Supper.
So the heading here is the beauty of littleness.
I think it's gorgeous.
And God performs his greatest works with the little ones.
And we're being introduced to one of the longer messages which you'll get used to as
you go on.
But Louisa said, I was abandoning all of myself in the arms of my sweet Jesus.
And while I was praying, I saw my soul so very little, but of an extreme littleness.
Now Jesus says to her in these writings that she's only an atom.
Now that's an extreme littleness, is that okay?
But there's something terribly important here.
And that is that when St. Therese of Lyseus was talking to the Lord.
The Lord told her that because she was little, he had done so much for her.
And she said to him, I'm not, this is not verbatim, it's only my memory.
And Therese said to him, if there was a soul littler than mine, would you do greater things
and he suggests?
And Jesus acknowledged that Louisa was the littler one.
Okay, so I think it must have really thrilled Therese to see her coming on.
So Louisa said, I saw that I was of an extreme littleness and I thought to myself, how little
I am, Jesus was writing telling, write in telling me that I'm the littlest of all.
So if you're the littlest of all, you can't get smaller.
Now while I was thinking this, my beloved Jesus moving in my interior showed me how
he took this little one in his arms and squeezed her tightly to his heart.
And she would let Jesus do whatever he wanted with her.
Now that's the operative bit that the little one allows the Lord to have his way.
And he told me, my dear little one, I have chosen you little because the little ones
let me do whatever I want.
Okay, my book says whatever he wants and it's the Lord who's speaking.
So that's Matthew 18 verses one to four.
I want you to become like little children, you remember?
The little ones do not walk by themselves, they let themselves be guided.
Even more, they are afraid to place one foot on their own.
So the image there is of a small child who's afraid to walk by himself or his herself.
If they receive gifts feeling incapable of keeping them, they place them on the lap of
their mother.
The little ones are stripped of everything.
Now that everything is ego, pride, worldliness, possessions, blah, blah, blah.
They're stripped of everything.
Or do they care about whether they are rich or poor?
So there's your detachment thing that was absolutely stressed in volumes one to four.
They are concerned with nothing.
Now, a small child is usually only concerned with being loved by the parents.
Oh how beautiful the tender age is full of grace, beauty and freshness.
Therefore, the greater the work that I want to do in the soul, the littler I choose her.
And you can see that from all the apparitions of Jesus and Mary around the world.
I like childlike freshness and beauty very much.
I like it so much that I preserve these souls in littleness of the nothingness from which
they came.
So here's your littleness and nothingness going together.
This nothing that he talks about is not a negative thing.
It's a very positive thing.
The nothingness is the safe place is what I call it.
Because you're safe from the attacks that come from yourself.
You're safe from the attacks that come from the world and you're safe from the attacks
that come from the demon.
So it's a very safe place to be.
And this nothingness is open to the allness of the Lord's presence.
So Jesus continued, I let nothing of their own enter into them.
So as not to let them lose their littleness and therefore preserve the divine freshness
and beauty from which they came.
Was it Jared Manley Hopkins that said that children come into the world trailing clouds
of glory from where they come from and that they remember it at least until somebody destroys
them.
So this divine freshness that comes from the Lord.
On hearing this, Louisa said, Jesus, my love, it seems to me that I am so very bad.
Now she's forever gone on about this and she won't let up even though Jesus tells her
to stop.
In volume 11, which we had last night, he said to her, if you keep going on about this,
he said, I want you to stop because you're offending me.
Now so you have to understand this so very bad, Louisa is talking about her feelings.
If you interpret bad as sin, she cannot be in this relationship as simple as that because
nothing unholy can enter the presence of God.
So it's like we would say, I got out the wrong side of the bed today, everything's upside
down, or I'm just not in a wonderful mood today or I'm just not feeling up to scratch
or whatever it is, she calls that so bad.
Okay.
And so it includes the coldness in prayer and all kinds of stuff.
And this is why I am so little.
It's actually not why she's so little.
And you are saying that you love me very much because I am little.
You see, she's saying I'm little because I'm so very bad.
That is not true.
And Jesus is going to explain the whole thing to her in great detail.
How can this be?
And Jesus said, my little one, badness, cannot enter the true little ones.
One, John, three, two.
For somebody who is truly in union with God, there is no sin.
Otherwise you're not in union with God, it's that simple.
Do you know when evil, when growth begins to enter, it's when one's own will begins to
enter?
Okay.
So I have Jeremiah to 13 beside that one.
So he says the problem, the badness begins when your own will enters into it.
And now as the human will enters, the creature begins to fill herself and to live out of
herself, my book says to live out of herself, you're living out of yourself.
The all goes out of the littleness of the creature.
And it seems to her that her littleness becomes greater, but greatness to be cried over.
So if we're stuffed up with ourselves and we're puffed up with our own importance, delete
littleness, then you would be bad.
You see the way Jesus is correcting her way of thinking, okay?
Because the littleness that he's talking about is a soul that has emptied itself of all the
stuff that it shouldn't have if it is to remain in union with God.
So since God does not live completely in the person who has let the human will enter, she
moves away from her beginning and dishonors her origin.
Now you should remember Eve in the garden because that's what happened, the human will entered
and they moved away from God, okay?
She dishonors her, she loses the light and the beauty and the sanctity and the freshness
of her creator.
She seems to grow before herself.
So if you're grating your own eyes, you certainly have not reached anything remotely like littleness.
And maybe before men, that's before humanity out there because human beings bow to people
who blow themselves up, but not before me, all how she decreases before me.
So if I'm grating my own eyes, I'm nothing in his.
If I'm nothing in my own eyes, I'm grating his.
Is that okay?
Now there is a text from the gospel that I should have remembered.
I'd give it to you in words, he who humbles himself will be exalted, but he who exalts
himself will be humbled.
I just don't know the text.
So oh how she decreases.
She may even become great, that is important in the world, but she will never be my beloved
little one because he likes the little ones as in full of God, empty of the world.
In whom taken by love for her, I fill with myself.
So you're either full of him or full of self.
So your cup either has tea or coffee in it.
It can't have the two.
And I fill her with myself that she may remain as I created her.
And I make of her the greatest whom no one will be able to equal.
Here is those who humble themselves will be exalted.
I make her great, but it's of a divine greatness.
But if we make ourselves great in the eyes of the world, then we forfeit the divine greatness.
So to me, that's a very good illustration of he who humbles himself will be exalted.
And this is what I did with my celestial mother, Jesus said, among all the generations, she
is the littlest of all.
Why is that? because she handed over her free will at the very first instance of her existence.
Because her will never entered into her as acting, but always it was my eternal will.
And this was only, and this not only kept her little, beautiful and fresh as she came out
from us, but made her the greatest of all.
So since she refused to let her human will have any life, then the divine will has its
full life in her.
That's why she's the greatest of all.
Oh, how beautiful she was, little in herself, but great and superior to all by virtue of
ourselves.
And only because of her littlest was she lifted up to the height of being mother of the one
who formed her.
Now there's the confirmation of the teaching that the church gave at one of its very earliest
meetings when the church declared her Teotokos, T-H-E-O is God, and T-O-K-O-S mother of God.
And there's the confirmation coming from the Lord himself.
So as you see, all the good of man lies in doing my will.
All the evil is in doing one's own.
Therefore in order to come to redeem man, I chose my mother because she was little.
And I used her as a channel, because that's what the Lord wants to do with each one of
us in so far as we are able to give ourselves to him, to use her as a channel in order to
let all the goods and the fruits of redemption descend upon the human race.
So that paragraph, if you want to put number one or A on it, then you put number two or
B on the next one.
So now that is in 1923, so that my will may be known and heaven might be opened to let
my will descend upon the earth and reign on it as it does in heaven, I had to choose another
little one among all the generations.
Now notice that in order to save us, redeem us, and sanctify us, the Lord wants to use
a person who is a part of the human race.
We have to participate.
It's our drop of water in his wine.
So I had to choose another little one among all the generations.
This is the greatest work I want to do to restore a man to his origin, from which he
came, and to open to him that divine will which he rejected, to open my arms to him
to receive him once again into the womb of my will, my infinite wisdom calls the little
one out of nothing.
So for that, I want to give you one Corinthians one, and I think it's from verse 18 to the
very end, which is about 36, God's foolishness versus the so-called wisdom of the world.
And we're not chosen because we're wise according to the ways of the world.
We're chosen because we should be little.
My infinite wisdom calls the littleest one out of nothing.
Now that's terribly important, if you just look back for a moment on the history of Louisa
herself that she had so much illness and trouble as a child, she missed most of her education
as in nine tenths of it.
And she's called out of this nothing to this incredible greatness.
But then you go back even further, and the Lord called the entire universe out of nothing
which is Genesis chapter one.
So if we are full of something, we're making ourselves unavailable to him.
Does that make sense?
And you can see that because people who are full of themselves at no time for church even.
It doesn't mean anything to them.
It was just that she would be little.
If I place a little one at the head of redemption, I had to place another little one at the head
of the fier polontas tour, secret in chalot et terra.
Between two little ones, I enclose the purpose of the creation of man.
So now you know why I gave you those two references at the very beginning.
Who is the greatest in the kingdom of God and who is the least in the kingdom of God?
Because it was the apostles who asked who was the greatest in the kingdom of God.
And James and John thought that they ticked all the boxes, you see?
Because they were thinking of kingdom on earth.
And Jesus said, "No, those places are reserved for the people whom the Father has appointed."
So we now know who have the places, our blessed mother and Louisa.
Why?
Because our blessed mother was the one chosen to bring redemption to the world and Louisa
was chosen, the one to bring the divine will to the world, not James and John.
Okay.
So that's why I gave you those references at the beginning.
So between these two little ones, I was to enclose the entire purpose of the creation
of man.
Now if Jesus had explained this to his apostles back at the very beginning, they wouldn't
have known what he was talking about because they were at the earliest stage of redemption.
So things can only be revealed at the right time.
I was to realize my designs upon him.
Through one, I was to redeem him, so that's step one in the process, to wash him of his
ugliness with my blood and to give him forgiveness.
And through the other one, which is step two, I was to make him return to his beginning,
to his origin, to his lost nobility, to the bonds of my will broken by him, admitting
him once again to the smile of my eternal will, kissing each other and live one within
the other.
Now bring the within thing because you're hearing that all the time that Jesus is living
within Louisa, okay?
And he comes out from within her interior.
And this is the reality that he wants is to live within us, like a living host, do you
remember?
So that living within, so the living within, that's Luke 17 again, 21, the kingdom of
God is within you.
So this alone was the purpose of the creation of man.
And what I have established, no one will be able to oppose.
Now he's talking now about the new era, just put new era in the margin there.
No one will be able to oppose.
I think that's wonderful news considering how bad things are in the church at the moment.
Centuries upon centuries will go by just as in redemption.
Now there's the answer to all the stuff you meet on YouTube that this is the end of the
world.
It's all going to be over in no time at all and the rapture came and went a few times,
you know what I mean?
So he says centuries and centuries will go by just as in redemption because it's going
to take time for this to filter out into the mass of people and for the church to begin
to pick it up, okay?
But man will return into my arms as he was created by me.
Now I remind myself of that every day when I hear bad news, the human race will come back
to me, he said, and that's that and whatever he declares is truth.
But in order to do this, first I have to choose the one who must be the first to live the
life of my eternal will, I must bind in her all the relations of creation and I must live
with her with no split of wills, that's the inseparability he talks about.
And with her will and ours as one, that means inseparable.
From here is the necessity that she be the littlest which we issue in creation so that
in seeing herself as so little she may shun her own will.
Now you see while we're being told in between the lines that the safe place from your own
will is your nothingness, okay?
Get into your nothingness and get to really love it.
Even more she may bind it so tightly to ours as to never do her will again.
And though little she may live together with us from the blowing of that breath with which
we created man, that's Genesis 2.7.
From the blowing of that breath with which we created man, our will preserves her fresh
and beautiful.
She forms our smile, our enjoyment, and we do with her whatever we want.
That's God's will being done.
Oh how happy she is now, this is Volume 16 and we've been told over and over that the
divine will is happiness and beatitude.
And enjoying her littleness and her happy destiny, notice enjoying her littleness.
It's only when you begin to feel the benefits of being in the nothingness that you begin
to enjoy it.
You see, if I am living in my nothingness and this person comes and either says or does
something very hurtful, okay?
Now when will I react?
It's when the ego is alive and my rights and I'll get back to you and blah, blah, blah.
It's the ego alive and very unhealthy.
But if I'm living in my nothingness, there's nothing to hurt.
And so the person actually loses all power to injure you.
Think about it, it's wonderful.
The person does not have the power to injure you in any way.
No matter what they do, they don't have that power.
You're in a very, very safe place, okay?
I love this, nothingness, it's one of the things I really like about this.
Oh how happy she is and enjoying her littleness and her happy destiny.
She will cry for her brothers, that's also interceding for others and will occupy herself
with nothing else but compensating us for all and for each one.
Just there you see the mission of giving glory to God and making reparation and substitution
for the rest of humanity to try and bring the rest of humanity into the fullness as well.
So she compensates us for all and for each one from all the wrongs that they do to us
by withdrawing from our will.
Now notice the source of evil and he has told us that about Adam and Eve also, that
the first stage of sin was simply to withdraw from the divine will and here you have it as
well, all the evil comes out of shifting away from the divine will.
The tears of one who lives in our will will be powerful, isn't that wonderful?
More so since she wants nothing but what we ourselves want.
Now one of the problems that people have in prayer in the other spiritualities that are
not into the divine will, that they can be working for their own sanctification and it's
things that they want for themselves and things that they want for individuals whom
they know and all the rest and it's all very confined and it's all very narrow.
Whereas when you come into the divine will, you don't want anything for yourself, you
only want everything for God and for humanity.
And so the whole movement is love, love towards God and love towards your neighbor.
That's why the divine will and love are the summary of the 36 volumes.
So if we're not growing in love, we're not growing in divine will.
So the tears of one who lives in our will will be powerful.
More so since she wants nothing but what we ourselves want and after the first channel
of redemption through her, we will open the second one of the feared Pilontas to on earth
as in heaven, okay.
So on hearing this Louisa said, "My love and my all tell me who will this fortunate little
one be?"
Doesn't cross her head that it's her.
"Oh how I would like to know her."
And he said, "What have you not understood?
It's you must be a terrible shock.
It's you, my little one," he said, "I've told you many times that you are the little
one."
No, he has told her many times, but I mean how often do you have to hear something before
your ears work?
And this is why I love you, he said.
Now so what I want to do there is give you Luke 1.52, he raises up the lowly.
You remember that, don't you?
And I want to give you Sam 138 verse 6, I want to give you Proverbs 3.34 and Proverbs 29.23.
He raises up the lowly, okay.
But as he was saying this, I felt Louisa said, I felt I was being transported out of myself
into a most pure light.
Now that is God and I usually only give you one reference for that, which is 1 John 1.5.
I came across a most obvious reference today and it's 1 Timothy 6.16, 1 Timothy 6.16.
God dwells in unapproachable light, okay.
God dwells in unapproachable light.
It's very important putting it with the other one, 1 John 1.5, okay.
God is light and he dwells in unapproachable light.
Now the ones who can approach that light are the eagles in the divine will.
We can only come a certain distance because we're creatures, at least on this side of
the divide.
So you're the little one.
But as he was saying this, I felt I was being transported outside of myself into a
most pure light in which one could see all generations, you see, looking into that light,
you can see everything that is in reality and therefore she sees the whole of humanity.
So if our eyes are focused on the Lord, we will be conscious of the journey that the
whole of humanity is taking, not just the one I'm on.
If I'm confined absolutely to my little bit and the few people that I know, then I'm
not there.
I don't have that sight.
Okay.
I could see all generations as though divided into two wings.
I love the two wings because if you're at that height, you're the eagle, okay.
One on the right and the other on the left of the throne of God, wing A, number one.
At the head of one wing, there was the august queen mother from whom descended all the goods
of redemption.
Oh, how beautiful was her littleness, marvelous, prodigious littleness, little and powerful,
little and great, little and queen, little with everyone hanging upon her littleness.
While she disposes of everything rules overall and only because she's little, she unfolds
the word within her littleness, making him descend from heaven to earth to let him die
for love of man.
So I want you to give yourself a title, maybe at the top of the page, the power of powerlessness.
The power of powerlessness is one of the great secrets of the spiritual life and I've illustrated
it for those of you who come to the scripture class because you saw that in Esther, for example,
the power of powerlessness.
You saw it in Daniel, the power of powerlessness, just to give you an example, okay.
But also if you go out into your garden and see the weeds, the reason why they're so prolific
and that they can get through, in my opinion, any obstacle I put in front of them is because
they're tiny and you put stones down on top of them and they'll find their way through
the stones, why?
Because they're little.
And so I think looking at weeds, what we call weeds, shows you the power of the little one.
And it's the tiniest plants like moss and lichens that conquer the rocks.
The big trees can't conquer the rock.
It's the tiny little ones who have got to prepare the soil and make soil and then something
bigger can grow in the soil and then something bigger and bigger, but it's the tiny ones
that conquer the rocks.
I think it's terribly important.
So the power of powerlessness is what you have in that littleness.
I think the place of littleness is wonderful.
Okay, at the head of the other wing, one could see the other little one, that's Louisa,
and I see it with trembling and obey, she was the one whom Jesus had called the little
daughter of his divine will.
I want to give you Sam 8.5, because Sam 8.5 says, "What is man that you would even take
any notions of?"
And yet you made him little less than a god and crowned him with glory and honor.
And this is the miracle of the littleness.
My sweet Jesus, placing himself in the middle of these two wings, you see the right and
the left in the kingdom of heaven?
That's why I gave you those texts at the beginning.
Between the two little ones who were the head of them, with one hand he took mine and at
the other he took the queen mother, and he joined them together saying, "My little
daughters hold each other's hand before our throne and embrace the eternal divine majesty
in your little arms.
To you alone, because you are little, it is given to embrace the eternal one, the infinite
one, and to enter into him."
Now notice the other thing that's being said without words, and that is, the human race
was pulled down by a woman and the human race is raised up by two women.
And when you come to the second half of the book of Revelation, you are given two images.
It's really one image, I suppose, and that is that woman takes everybody to heaven with
her if she's glorious and crowned with stars, and she has the glory of God all over her.
She'll take everybody to heaven with her.
If she doesn't do that, if she falls, she becomes the terrible harlot and she takes
everybody to hell.
You're the glorious woman in chapter 12, and you're the terrible harlot in chapter 17.
And that's the choice for the human race.
We either take everybody to heaven or everybody to hell.
And it's interesting that the image is woman, because the one who brought the human race
down was the woman, and it doesn't do anybody any good by not admitting the truth.
So to you alone, because you are little, it is given to embrace the eternal one, the
infinite one.
Now, there's the nothing embracing the all.
It's really fantastic.
And to enter into him, you see, and nothing unholy or unworthy can enter into him.
Okay, you have to be one with him.
And if the first one snatched redemption from the love of the eternal one, so made the second,
or hand held by the first, because the first one is greater than the second, isn't it right?
Be helped by her to snatch from the eternal love of the fiat volantis to an on earth as
it is in heaven.
One of the things that fascinates me reading this is the sheer detail of the plan.
Everything is in an absolutely correct order.
Now, who can say what happened, Louisa, said, "I have no words to be able to express myself.
I can only say that I remained more humiliated and confused, and almost like a fussy little
girl.
I wanted my Jesus in order to tell him about my fears, about my doubts, or she's back to
square one."
Now she takes refuge in that, you know, "I've got to tell him all my problems," you see.
You've got to remember that at this early stage in the 20th century, it was a kind of
normal practice, certainly in convents, whether they did it among lay people or not, I couldn't
tell you, that they'd force over their faults and their failings, and they'd keep the confessor
for ages, and they'd talk the thing out until you'd driven mad.
I remember once asking a priest, not in early part of the 20th century when it wasn't alive.
This man was a confessor to a community of enclosed nuns, I better not tell you the order.
And I said to him, "How do you endure confession from these women?"
And he looked at me and he said, "You seem to understand."
I said, "I have a grave suspicion because I give them retreat."
He said, "Woman, it's like being pelted to death with peanuts and you don't die."
He said, "You can't die."
In other words, they're telling little details, minutiae, and there's nothing more horrendous,
do you know what I mean?
So they're obliged to go to confession.
He's obliged to hear the confession, so they're all being crucified, the whole of them.
It's fascinating.
So here's Louisa getting back to the little minutiae as well, and I think that's a kind
of comfort zone.
It's a place I understand.
It's a place that is familiar.
I've just been taken up into this very unfamiliar place, and it's so exotic and it's so exalted
and everything, and it's like if you've had an absolutely marvellous retreat at a weekend
or something, you've been flying high, and there's nothing more wonderful than the comfort
of Monday morning after it, and you get down to perfectly ordinary things like washing clothes
and washing dishes and cleaning the house, and it's the familiarity.
That's where I put Louisa's reaction there, to get back to something normal.
And so she said, "I prayed that he would cast all these things away from me."
Now she has no idea what she's saying, because if he cast it all away from her, none of the
rest of us could enter the divine will, so she doesn't realize what she's saying.
And I feared that the mere thought of them was a subtle pride, and that he would give
me the grace to really love him and to do his most holy will in everything.
And then my beloved Jesus, coming back again, made himself seen inside of me, another assess
the living host, and my person served as though to cover him inside of me, there's your living
host thing.
"And without letting me speak," he told me, "my poor little one, what do you fear?
Courage, I am the one who will do everything in my little daughter."
As Ephesians 2, 10, we are God's work of art, Ephesians 2, 10.
You will do nothing but follow me faithfully, won't you?
You are right that you are too little, and you can do nothing, but I will do everything
in you.
That's Philippians 4, 13.
I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength.
I also want to give you Philippians 1, 6, that the Lord will complete the work he has
begun in you, if you let him.
And he's forever saying to Louisa, "Let me do, let me do, give me a chance."
Don't you see that I am within you, there's your Luke 17, 21, and that you are nothing
but a shadow that covers me.
Now I think if you're talking about nothingness to call yourself a shadow is about it, you've
arrived.
What's there?
It's only a shadow, okay.
I am the one who will cross within you the eternal and on ending boundaries of my will.
Now when you go up into the high volume 20s, up into the 30s, you see her wandering around
in the interminable place of the divine will, it's incredible.
And you'll hear her saying, "There's no way out of this, there's no way out of this."
I am the one who will embrace all generations in order to bring them together with your
shadow.
He needs our drop of water in the wine of his redemption and his sanctification.
He needs our tiny little bit of participation.
Just like saying that a mother lets a child be mommy's little helper, and the child is
making an awful mess of the stuff, but the child is learning to participate.
I think I've said this to you before, they're one of the most wonderful things I've ever
seen is in Africa they get children to participate from day one.
You're going to say to me, that's not possible.
You have to be in Africa to know that it is.
So the mother is holding this infant that can be a day or two old, and the child must
participate.
So she takes the child's hand and she wraps the child's hand around a spoon, and she puts
that spoon into the pot where she's making the main meal for the day and the child with
the mother's hand around it, does the turn of the pot, and then the child is put back
in his little cradle.
You've participated.
You must participate, and this is one of the aspects of this that fascinates me, that
we must participate.
I mean, the Lord could do all this by himself, but then he'd be treating us as not his children,
not his own.
Do you know what I mean?
And he wants to be able to say that the mystical body of Christ did this with him.
So it's Christ and his body that's working together.
Is that okay?
So I'll do them together with your shadow to the feet of the eternal one so that the
two wills, the human and the divine, may kiss each other, may smile at each other, and may
no longer look at each other like strangers, which is what happens when the human will
is separated from the divine.
So like strangers being separated, scowling at each other, but one may be fused within
the other, okay, that is fused to remain such, forming one single will.
It is the power of your Jesus that must do this.
You must do nothing but adhere.
In other words, you cling on, let him do it.
I know, I know that you are nothing and you can do nothing.
And this is why you afflict yourself, but it is the strength of my arm that wants and
can operate.
And I like to operate great things in the littlest ones.
And besides, the life of my will has already been on the earth.
It's not completely new because it was in Adam and Eve first, and then it was in Jesus
and Mary.
Okay.
Before I go any further, I have a string of things in the margin to give you.
Sam 44 verse 3, that's Sam 44 verse 3, Sam 77 verse 15, Sam 89 verse 13, Isaiah 51 verse
9, Luke 1, 51, and John 12, 38, that's quite a bit, but it's all talking about us letting
the Lord have his way, he will do it, but he does want somebody on the earth cooperating
with him.
And the more of us, therefore, that get into the divine will, the more he can accomplish
on the earth and the faster he can do it.
So he says, "And besides, the life of my will has already been on the earth.
It's not completely new, although it was as though in passing.
It existed in my inseparable and dear mother.
If the life of my will had not been in her, I, the eternal word, could not have descended
from heaven.
I would have lacked the way through which to descend, the room into which to enter, the
humanity with which to cover my divinity."
So you notice he needed a living host, the food to nourish myself.
I would have lacked everything for that, I want to give you Amos 3 3, Amos 3 3, because
all other things are not suitable for me.
That is anything pertaining just of the human.
But by finding my will in my beloved mother, I found my very own heaven, because heaven
is where God is, and the divine will is the operating part of God.
I found my very own heaven, my joys and my contentment.
At most I exchanged my dwelling from heaven to earth, but as for the rest I changed nothing.
That which I had in heaven, I found on earth by virtue of the will possessed by her.
And therefore, with all love, I descended into her to take on human flesh.
Then my will had its life on earth in my humanity, which is of course the Holy of Holies.
By virtue of which I formed the redemption.
Not only this, but by virtue of my will, I laid myself over all the works of the human
generations, sealing them with my divine acts and beseeching my father, not only to redeem
man, but that at the appropriate time, man might win the favor of our will.
So we were able to imitate him and offer him the divine version of all humanity, ask
him to seal with his divine acts, all the acts of creatures to raise them up.
So he said, "At the appropriate time, man might win the favor of our will," which is
Louise's time, "as when he was created, so as to live according to the purpose wanted
by us, that the will of heaven and that of earth be one; therefore, everything was done
by me, the plain of redemption and that of the fear that belonged to us on earth as in
heaven."
Now he talks about the plain, so let me show you this.
We can say there are different planes and one is the plane of the world down here, where
people are following their ego and their human will and all the rest of it.
The second one, in my opinion, is the ordinary spirituality that the entire church is living.
And the third one is the plane of the divine will and you have to go through the ordinary
spirituality to get up there, unless the Lord catapults you up there.
That's his business.
But there are different planes of operating.
And you know that the people who are living, are trying to operate in space, are operating
on completely different principles than somebody driving a car on the earth.
And so these planes, I will talk to you about them in dramaty.
These planes are terribly important to know what are the principles of living on the different
ones.
Be sure we have shifted from one to the other or that we have shifted completely as I think
would be the problem.
Okay.
So he said, "Everything was done by him naturally because he's God and man, the plane of redemption
and that of the fear of Atlantis to earth as in heaven.
It would not have been a work worthy of me had I not rehabilitated man in everything
as he was created.
It would be a work halved on, not whole.
And your Jesus does not know how to do incomplete works.
At the most I wait centuries.
Look at the patience of God.
Of course you do know that Sam is at 90 or 91 verse 3 says, "With the Lord a thousand
years is like a single day."
So he waited a few minutes.
At most he said, "I wait centuries to give the complete good prepared by me.
Therefore don't you want to be with me in giving man the work which I completed with
my coming upon the earth.
So be attentive and faithful and do not fear.
I will always keep you little so as to be able to complete more of my designs on you."
Now there's a big answer to a question you will be asked by people right there.
And that is, is this revelation made to Louisa, is it completely new?
And the answer to that is yes and no.
And then they say, "No, you can't predict it, just that means no you haven't."
Because Jesus did everything.
And just this is the time for the revealing of what Jesus did on this plane.
We were already completely familiar with what he did on the plane of redemption.
But he did everything on this plane as well, that's what you're told here.
But that now is the time to reveal it which is a different subject.
Is that okay?
Very important answer there because people will ask you that question.
So let's do at least a little of the next one, November the 15th, 1923.
So we're talking about the divine will here.
And look at the heading.
In order to come to reign upon the earth, the divine will wants to find one.
This all applies to us now.
One who will receive it, as number one, who will understand it, number two, who will love
it, number three, because we're not going to live it if we haven't received it, understood
it, and loved it, okay?
So Louisa said, "I felt as though sunken in the holy will of God, and it seemed to me
that in my interior my sweet Jesus enjoyed himself very much in sending me light, and
I felt as though it eclipsed within that light."
So you now have another reference for the light, haven't you?
That's 1 Timothy 6, 16.
Don't know why I left that one out all the time.
I felt my mind being filled so much that I could not contain it to the point where I
said, "Jesus, my heart, don't you know that I am little?
I can't contain what you want to put in my intelligence."
And Jesus said, "Little daughter of mine, do not fear.
Your Jesus will let you drink this light in sips so that you may receive it and understand
it."
Okay, so before you move, I want to give you Luke 16, 10, and Luke 19, 17, and Matthew
25, 23.
So Luke 16, 10, Luke 19, 17, and Matthew 25, 23.
And the subject is, "If you are faithful in little things, I will give you a greater,
and there's several parables involved there."
Do you remember the pounds and all the rest of it?
And what he says is, "He trains us in little things, and if you will be faithful in the
little things, he will give you something bigger, and see will you be faithful in that.
And if you're faithful in that, he'll give you something bigger."
And that's this thing of, you know, you're sent away to trade the five pounds to see what
you will do with it.
And then it's the person who did more with the gift that was given to them than was given
the extra that the other person had rejected.
Now, that's what you're told here as well.
The people in the divine will, who will be faithful and who will use what God has given
to them, will in fact be given graces rejected by others.
Okay.
So I let you have it in sips.
I like that idea.
I don't know about you.
So that you may receive it and understand it.
Do you know what this light means?
It is the light of my will, okay?
So there's your one Timothy 616 again.
The light of my will, it is the divine will rejected by other creatures, which wanting
to come to reign upon the earth wants to find someone who will receive it, understand it,
and love it.
And those are the three things that he wants.
In order to come to reign, I want to find a little soul.
That's why for us getting into the nothingness is rather urgent, who would offer herself to
receive all these acts which the Supreme will has destined for each creature.
So we have to be willing to receive what all the others don't want to have.
So I want to find a little soul who would offer herself to receive all those acts which
the Supreme will had destined for each creature to make them happy and holy and to give them
the goods it contains.
Now this happiness, sanctity and goods, which the eternal will issued in order to communicate
them to the creature as it issued the whole of creation are out.
That means ready for use, they're given.
And they are suspended because not too many people are actually using them.
So that's number one.
And the divine will, if the divine will does not find one who will receive them so as to
give it all the homage, honor and courtage that the other creatures have not given to
it, it cannot come to reign upon the earth.
So if it doesn't find someone to receive, it can't come.
Therefore your task is to embrace all generations in order to receive all the acts of the Supreme
will that they rejected together with all the goods it contains.
No wonder Louisa said she couldn't take anymore because if my capacity is this and he's pouring
in graces from all generations then it would overflow rather quickly.
And so what you'll find he's going to tell us that he keeps expanding the soul to be able
to take more.
So if there's no one to take it, it cannot come to reign upon the earth.
Therefore your task is to embrace all generations in order to receive all the acts of the Supreme
will that they have rejected together with all the goods that it contains.
If you do not do so, my eternal will cannot put itself in feast to come and reign.
It will have the tears of the past sorrow.
In other words, we'll just go on with human beings doing their own will, of how ungrateful
it was rejected.
And one who cries does not reign.
Therefore the divine will wants that the acts of its volition destined for each creature
receive reparation.
Here's our job.
Not only this, but it wants someone who would love wants to receive its happiness and what
it contains.
So there's the Lord coming like a beggar asking for someone to actually receive him, first
of all, and to begin to accept something of what he wants to give.
Louisa responded, "Jesus, my love, how can I do this?
I am too little and also bad."
You see, she said it again, "That's my feelings and you know it.
Even more I fear I am unable to do it even for myself.
How can I do it for others?"
And it's a very important question because that may not be Louisa's question.
It may be a question put into her to answer a problem for us because we might be saying
how can we possibly do this?
And he said, "This is precisely why I have chosen you and I keep you little so that you
may do nothing by yourself."
Because you remember the rule we were given?
If you desire it, I'll do it, do you remember it?
But you'll do it always together with me.
I too know that little as you are, you are good at nothing.
At the most of making me smile with your trifles, therefore your Jesus will take care of everything.
That's like a parent saying to a child, "It's okay, mommy or daddy will take care of it."
And the child relactes because the darn thing is going to be looked after.
So this is necessary, Jesus said, "Just as it was necessary so that I might come to accomplish
the redemption that a little daughter of ours, my mother, take on as her task to receive
within herself all the acts of our will rejected by creatures."
She made them her own.
She welcomed them with decorum.
She loved them, repaired them, requited them to the point of filling a hole, their whole
expanses as much as it is possible for a creature.
So when the divinity saw in this little one, its will for creation reintegrated.
Not only for herself, but for all others.
It felt so drawn that in addition to the many acts of its will in creation, it emitted the
greatest act, the most sublime, the most prodigious, that this little one be the one to be raised
to the exclusive and unique dignity of the mother of her very creator.
There's your Teotichos again, beautiful description of it.
"I, the eternal word, could never have descended from heaven had I not found my will in her
reintegrated just as we wanted it to be in the creature.
What was then the cause that made me come upon the earth?
It was my will existing in a little creature.
There you have the big, big, big answer.
How is the Lord going to return to the earth and it is in people who will live in the divine
will?"
That is returned to the earth.
What did I care that she was little?
All I cared about was that my will was safe in her.
Now put a big N.B. beside that one as well, that the divine will is actually safe in us,
we're not going to abuse it, and that there would be no split on the part of her human
will.
In other words, the human will and the divine would be inseparable.
Once our will was safe, all our rights were restored and the creature could place herself
in order with the creator and the creator would place himself in order with the creature.
In other words, the reconciliation between God and man happened.
The purpose of creation was already fulfilled, therefore we came to the acts, the deeds,
that the word would be made flesh first to redeem man and then so that our will be done
on earth as it is in heaven.
First things first, if man is not redeemed, he's not going to come back into the divine
will, so the redemption has to be first.
Ah yes, it was my mother who, taking it to herself, the whole of our will issued for
the good of creation, darted through the divinity with divine arrows, there would be arrows
of love, in such a way that wounded by our own arrows, the word was drawn into her womb
like a powerful magnet.
Look at the power of love, the great magnet of life.
Something can we deny to the one who possesses our will, put a big envy beside that one,
will you?
For someone who possesses the divine will, the Lord will not reject, whatever you ask.
See then, the necessity for which I want another creature to offer herself, to receive into
herself all the acts of my will which I issued in creation, so as to give completion to that
fiat, which I came to bring upon the earth, and which was welcomed and understood only
notice that word by my mother, and was only understood by her because she alone was living
the divine will.
And this is why there was no division between me and her.
The divinity wants to be wounded once again with its own darts, in order to give the generations
this great good that my will will reign in them.
Since this is the greatest thing, it wants to give the true origin of man, a human will
is not enough to intercede for this, and even less is it strong enough to wound the divinity.
But it takes a divine will with which the soul filling herself with it may wound her
creator with his own arrows, and there you have an answer again, why do you have to pray
in the divine will?
The divine will alone has the power to operate on the divine level, and therefore have the
power to really move God to do things.
So filling herself with the divine will, the soul may wound her creator by his own arrows,
we love him with his own love, we adore him with his own iterations and so on.
In such a way that wounded, he may open the heavens to let his will descend upon the earth.
Now you'll get a first inkling of this in Isaiah 64 verses 1 to 2.
Open the heavens and come down is what Isaiah said, because only if you come down from the
heavens can the human race recover.
Then he came down in redemption first, and then he's coming now in the divine will.
More so since he will find his noble courtage, all the acts of his will lined up in the creature
who has snatched from him this solemn act, that his will come on earth with his complete
triumph.
Now I'm going to stop there, even though it's the middle of a message, because our time
is up, and we'll complete that the next day, is that okay, there's a lot there.